like I've been flying to Johnson's August and
feel like worthless.
Because you know, like, and again.
statistically I'm like watching all the things and people are like
and employee for two years, like the average unemployment
time is six months, like whatever.
So I know it's--
It's not just me, but it's just like...
I don't think I actually thought I'd like be.
out like this long even though I know his story.
It's taken me a long time to find jobs when I wanted to know.
You know, we just like, right?
like every day when you're like, "Oh, it's eight months."
and I'm not one shot closer to anything.
Yes.
I understand how things can accrue over time, but it has
a thing happened recently that's just exacerbating it.
I think like I didn't
expect not to get that job like that red bean jar.
Like it makes no sense like even you're like why they
interviews are not ready. Like, you know, it's like that I was kind of
like oh I'll probably like just
based on everything I assumed I would get it,
whether it would be the right fit.
or the right offer.
And then like--
I got hit twice for like this CBRE.
role like from a CBRE recruiter and then
like a facilities recruiter, but like...
like the first like the CBRE recruiter then was like, oh, the hiring.
manager says you need to have hard services.
then like the other recruiter hit me I'm like yeah apparently like I'm
I'm already disqualified for this role.
- So it's just kind of like...
Nothing in the pipeline.
And Wally is going to quit at the end of the week.
have nothing also.
It's just that bad for him.
Yeah, he is like.
Nick is like a fucking dick he says.
And it's just like really bad.
They're like micromanaging him and like
like, he's a genix.
guy like Frank wants all of his own people.
And he's a generalist.
person regardless whether he's like.
acting, talking about it or not, you know.
like so they're just like building a case.
that he is not good and...
Yeah, it's awful.
Yeah, I feel bad.
Yeah, it's...
That's all.
of shitty stuff that's happening I mean
At the very least I can say I don't blame you for feeling...
pretty dejected right now.
Yeah, it's like I don't know.
I spent like hours with Claude.
Claude and I were working on my resumes.
Yeah, the last couple hours.
And so...
Okay, working on your resume, have you gotten
feedback about your resume not.
like featuring certain things.
Just curious.
- No, so like, I mean...
The only person I asked was like that woman you saw.
email where I was like, hey, open to your feed.
back and she didn't like give me like I've asked a couple people
like I'm like hey do you have any feedback or like when I like network.
work with recruiters or whatever, I'm like attached as my resume.
if you have any connections or feedback, no one ever likes.
says anything and like that lady didn't
say anything so like but I was like
like, you know, because, you know, we've talked about how
using AI, it's all about the prompts.
So I'm like, "Based on my recipe."
based on like this resume.
Why do you think?
I think I'm not getting interviews.
And then--
'Cause I did do like a ops resume.
resume in a relationship resume.
- Okay. - Again, like I can't,
it's hard 'cause like I can't.
I can have a resume for every single individual job,
but I--
like it like, split it out.
- Yeah.
- And then it was like...
It was like, it was like,
Essentially it was saying that like my resume is...
like trying, still trying to...
include both but doing neither.
service. Okay. You know, like it was like ops and.
relationship, whatever.
And then it's--
said that it was like missing like certain like
certain keywords like P and L or like whatever.
So we went back and forth for like probably
two hours, Claude and I, like Claude asking.
questions and like me answering and like it reviving.
and we're rising and we're rising.
And then I like.
two versions I have an ops and a relationship one which is like this.
- Same shit, just written differently.
The reason that I'm asking...
about the resume situation is
because
like with applying the jobs right now and how
Applications are being managed from...
by recruiting and how that's all.
being handled internally like I think
is going to be a crash at some point.
relatively soon where like the whole process of a plan
the jobs through the internet is going to be a good job.
to just fall apart because they're it's just
Just robots talking to robots.
There isn't anybody who is really looking at it and the only
way that people are going to actually become employed anymore.
is by having like warm.
leads. Right. And so I.
Because you've been doing this for eight years.
months. I'm not going to insult you by asking you if-
you've tried to get any warm leads.
Yeah.
I mean like I so like a lot
of my time was it like had
equally even spent like trying to make.
that connection. So I did have
like not as much like in the in now but
Like in the beginning, I had like a good amount of like
converse.
conversations with connections which like weren't
just for jobs like like there wasn't a job.
that made sense or like there was a job but it wasn't like necessary.
like an interview was more like a like.
networking. So like I've had conversations.
with like some of the other things that we have to do.
Somebody at KBS, someone at ABM.
So I'm gonna harbor like...
I have gotten recruiters at like
and Daxxo to refer like to do like an end.
I've gotten people at Jane Jay to do like the
internal referral, BMS, MIR.
You know, so like that was kind of where I was like, hey,
like if you know of anything and then like people be like,
hey, let's just.
Let's see like if anything comes up in the new year and the
like that didn't lead to anything.
But that was like what I was targeting.
first because I was like, oh like...
end of the year there weren't as many jobs, you know, like posts.
And then I was like,
I can't get through as we know the AI.
like can you get do you have someone who can do like an entire.
like, you know, cause those
just get through the system differently.
So I've done some.
I'm a little loose.
I'm not even gonna lie, like so, 'cause I have ADHD.
and like all ADHD meds are
controlled substances like I see a doctor monthly right to you.
prescription, even she was like, oh,
I was just talking to someone who was having a hard time.
filling roles and like was like with your permission I could do these.
things made a connection and that lady never followed up with
me and I was like I don't I was straight up
I was like, I'm not 100% sure that I'm like a fit for what she's--
looking for but I'd love to like connect a network with
her, you know, like if she's open to it.
And then in my last--
I'm sure this like woman ever contact you and I'm like now.
And she's like she should have and then the woman like did a policy
white LinkedIn message and then was like, hey, what--
are you looking at and then like never read my message or message track?
of yeah just.
that the willingness to ghost people.
people. Just people are just
easily tempted into ignoring things.
or they have, you know, for giving them the best.
of the doubt, you know, at most they.
just have too much crap coming towards them and it's hard for them.
for them to keep track of it all.
But that, I mean, that's all.
like to have that happen when
It feels like it's a genuine...
prospect for you and that like
warmly and is happening there that that really is terrible.
Yeah, man. I mean, I
And now it's like just a crazy.
time and plus like.
Like not that there's always an excuse, but it's like at the end.
the air, it's slower, Q1 is going to be slow, people are
waiting to get their bonuses through March. So like I get
all of that not to like make an excuse.
you for it, but that's
frustrating very much.
Yeah, for sure.
The next thing that I wanted to ask you about.
is... I...
I'm not saying this because and hopefully
I'm not repeating myself with you here, but I'm not saying this because I
I've been like entrepreneur,
Pilled or anything like that.
Um, because I'm not like I see so.
I see so much bullshit on LinkedIn like everyone.
ever since I changed my fucking title to it.
founder like now, I don't actually
I see anything from people that I know is just a bunch of other entrepreneurs.
and it's irritating as hell. However,
Um, given the...
experience mix that you that you
you have. I wonder if...
there's any like public sector
contracting work that you would be eligible for that you
could bid on as like a.
as like a sole proprietor, as like somebody.
operating by themselves.
Has that ever come up in...
in any of the angles that you've been trying to take.
So like...
while Lee proposed that like in the very beginning.
like when I had resigned but
It was still like on my exit.
it tour with like CSI and because he was
particularly like in the Bay area.
like new of like he had a contact to
kind of did the like buying of small contracts.
and then like, you know, that kind of thing.
and he was like talked about doing it.
And then I...
I think he reached out to like his contact.
and then as contact goes like, "I'm not in the market anymore."
And we didn't necessarily talk about it again.
And then, and again, like I said,
like I would need probably do like multiple times.
Like I would still be looking for a drought like you know any like trying
to sustain a job or an income of some.
kind while like trying to do something to get it off the ground.
and then I talked to you.
him about like, um, consultant.
like because his dad like sometimes does a little bit of
a lot of consulting, but then his dad was like,
like, a--
specifically because I was like think about it like.
instead of kind of like a startup type of...
thing like where you go in and you build like their program.
like what we had to do for like BMS ads.
CSI, like build their life science program.
the KPIs, all the safety stuff like established.
shit, etc. And then, but his dad said the market.
It's like so penetrated for that.
- Mm.
So I don't like thought about it.
And then I was like looking at like this week.
I was looking at certifications and I'm like, am I gonna...
I have to get my like, F.
because...
You know like while he'd want to do it because like
like this is his field, one like his, he's like.
wants it. He's like, he wants again to heart services.
be a true FM like an IFM manager except for the new.
for me I'm like it
It's like, it doesn't have to be this industry.
Like I don't--
or like it's more of like a skill or a job or something.
responsibility type of thing.
Some like--
Am I gonna have to like get this because this is
like where I progressed in my career.
career and like where I'm heading and like this will be helpful.
like would CB would CB re have like
like, inter-read me if I had it even without.
hard service experience.
I mean, obviously that is an answer.
angle that you can take, but...
I feel like you're also asking a really important question.
question, which is like, is
this is the industry that you want to stay in.
Like cause...
The way that you characterize it with Wal-E,
it sounds like that's--
for a conclusion. I get it that, you know, it's
his blood and it's what his dad did and stuff.
But--
you've been in this industry.
for a while, but is this necessary?
the one path that you need to take.
Let's set aside just economic concern.
because I know that can be hard when you have been.
but it's still worth talking about it.
Yeah, I mean for me like it's not.
Like I'm not like, don't move.
Like I'm not.
I have nothing wrong with what I didn't.
not like any of the things, my career, my jobs.
like it's like there are pieces of it.
There are like a...
company pieces that I didn't like but the overall
job. I don't mind and I like it.
like I like problem solving, I like client relationships.
like process, I like you know all that.
the mentorship and like the
team building all those pieces, but like that could be.
anywhere. You know what I mean? Right.
So that's where I'm like, it doesn't have to be facilities.
And if I work for like one more company within this.
that's just disgusting.
get to have to like jump off.
cliff because I don't understand why this industry
like they're just all disgusting people.
you know, like Marvin, Mike Barry, like those people.
People like personally destroyed me.
like they had no gay.
out of it. You know what I mean? Like if SVM
wants to join me or blacklist me as a company like okay.
like it's not right, but it's business.
But like...
Marvin and Mike Barry, like those...
Those were personal attacks.
And what did they gain out of it?
It's not like any of these millions.
the dollars went to their pockets like honestly they
probably wouldn't have even lost their jobs.
mean they we weren't going to win it all.
Record.
and they wouldn't have lost their jobs.
They've been with SBM.
for a bajillion years, they're cool-aid drinkers.
Right.
- So it's like you personally...
ruin my life to a degree like I know in dramatic.
like you know like Frank
all these people, these are like personal attacks.
And that's what like I'm like if it's in if this
is like industry specific, that's where I'm like I'm.
I don't want to do that.
100% and that is
That's in line with what I've been...
I'm not like renouncing j--
editorial or facilities because that is
where I've been working for the last five years.
But yeah, like there is a lot of just...
really unscrupulous behavior that
happens within the industry and
And it just attracts just
really awful people in a lot of ways.
So I 100%--
Get wanting to distance yourself.
from it. And if you want to avoid
wherever you go there you are scenario.
that it sounds like you've found yourself.
and I feel like I found myself and then yeah.
you might need to divest yourself of the industry.
Yeah, I mean, it's like...
Well, again, like I don't know, like I came
from like the vitamin industry and I worked for like
some really shitty companies, what really shitty people.
So it's hard to like...
like is at all is this just like a personal.
and all like moral issue or is it like an image?
industry or is it like all industries are
going to have shit, you know.
Well, I mean, that's it's for that reason that I've
also made the decision to try to do
something by myself because I...
I've also been in multiple industries.
and I've just found it.
If not outright like personally repulsive behavior.
behavior that I found just
idiotic choices and
really
decision-making pretty much wherever I've gone.
And so not tethering myself.
to accompany in perpetuity.
has been my attempt at it.
to try to solve that situation.
I don't have any paid engagements yet, but...
I mean, I'm just as unemployed as you are right now.
right now. I haven't been unemployed for as long as you've
I've been by by any means so I don't want to draw too
straight of a line, but the fact is, is that like,
what...
what I feel like I'm doing here.
and working towards feels more productive than
if I were trying to apply to a lot of people.
lot of jobs is my point.
Yeah.
No, I could see that. Words like...
You know and I could like your
like you have to put the work in like you said like it's been a couple weeks
or a month or whatever amount of time that you've been like putting
into it so like...
There's no measurables, right?
Like it's not to say.
you're not there yet to say you're unsuccessful or.
I'm not, and I know that's not what you said.
I'm just like.
you know, growing it out there. We're so like...
what you're working towards something.
And I...
done like different like thoughts of
like when I was home after having a
I stayed home for a bit and like I
did like mommy and me type of classes.
and try to create this thing and then.
It's like the long-term commitment of...
of getting it off the ground.
You know what I mean?
Like I need like I at some point I need
to like sustain a like regular.
income in addition to you or
until so that was kind of like the killer
for that plus like the person I like.
was partnered with like she was like I was like I want.
this to be a thing and she was like, I'm good if this was like...
like really just a club and something I do like for fun.
when I have time, so it was like different visions.
you know, like she was like, I'll teach one or two classes.
that fits in my schedule and I was like,
I'm teaching three classes.
day like you know it's like
not the same momentum.
So yeah, no.
I get it, but I think like regardless of
of what I do, I have to land like.
something for like an income day.
as I continue to do those things.
And that's like kind of like trying
stand like what would that be?
I even like my daughter's part, like I hosted like my daughter's part.
birthday party and I was like listen if I'm gonna have
this party at like one of those stupid places is gonna call
like $1,000.
I could buy all these stupid sleepover attention.
and stuff for like six hundred
$100, get every single thing.
like we get to keep you guys like instead of like.
wearing the robe and returning it, your friends get to keep it.
And we just had this like epic.
at home party that everyone loved.
And yes, now I have all stuff below.
like it's all safety money in the long run.
- Yeah.
like another like mom of like
like, oh my daughter wants to party or whatever.
like such a idea that should be your side gate. I was like yeah I always thought.
about like event planning or whatever and then she's
like wanted to hitch her wagon to me and I'm like mmm.
You don't seem like you're gonna like contribute.
in the way that I need contribution.
like like she wanted to she's like
But yeah, she's like, let me too.
I've thought about it.
Let's just--
like seriously discuss like starting
something and I'm like oh yeah okay.
So I mean it sounds like...
you're wary about partnering.
with people because you've been burned in the
past. Well yeah and I just know this one too.
She's kind of sneaky, but you take people for...
who they are, right? Like she's one of my neighbors.
her kids fly. Like I know who she is, I know what to expect.
and like I'm not putting any extra weight or getting offended by it.
you know, and I'm like, like in my
mind I'm like it must be nice to find a smart person.
and hit your wagon too was like my immediate reaction.
whereas there are other people like,
if I were to do something like that.
while the aid like I know that, you know, we each have.
have come lamenting skill sets and...
would it would be fine, like it'd be an equal or like I have
like another friend who said like she's always wanted to do that too.
And she's always like tried to convince me, but then she's like
openly, but I'm not serious about it right now.
kind of thing, but like I would do something with her.
Right. You know.
like so it depends.
the so the
The thing I was thinking about before with
If your situation is like you've
You've come back to...
of times about like you would love to do something I'm your
around, but you would need to have income in the meantime.
And this is not a knock against you. I'm not saying
this as a knock against you Jenna but the fact is is that you're
you're looking for that thing right now and...
don't have that income, right?
is sure and I'm not saying and like
But it's a logical point that I'm trying to make.
like if all things being equal,
you have the same level of income coming in
while you're trying to get it.
trying to build this thing.
I don't know that you're--
actually really losing anything by doing it.
Sure. I mean, I could see that.
'cause I was thinking like the other day when I was thinking.
I was looking at the different
like certifications and stuff.
Like,
I was like, "Oh, should I?"
get like my life coaching.
certification because that's like
Obviously, it's like a pretty big thing and then like also like
like I was like looking at the different community colleges and
like that was one of them.
And then I was like, but what?
like a long term like am I gonna be a life coach?
Like, you know what I mean?
And like, I've done this a lot of times.
because I'm a money-driven person. So like I...
So like someone told me I might have told you this before.
but like someone's when we, there's like,
everyone chases one thing in life.
it's money, happiness, or comfort. And I, oh.
been like a money chaser like kind of just
that was like, whether I wanted to be or not.
that like became my role and like our wrote Mary.
because my husband's like a comfort person.
Not to say...
that he doesn't contribute like he does.
obviously but like he's like
just like he's been with the same company.
since like college graduation he left for like
maybe six months and then went back and he's
Like, oh, like, I'm good, I'm comfortable.
Like, I have--
flexible schedule like I could get away like.
with all these things like whatever.
So like any time.
there was like a like and not to say he wouldn't have done
it. It's just the role that I'd always taken like where I'll
like if we needed more I'd go for like I'd go.
didn't like this job, I'd go to another one
and make more money.
know, push like whatever. Though like
obviously like he's figuring it out now.
You know, so it's like, and he's like, I'll work.
10 jobs if that's what we need. I need like kind of...
thing, but it's just like, then our roles and I put that.
pressure on to myself always.
So like I was like, I will be miserable because.
I sold my soul for money, right?
what's your whore price essentially it's like.
You know, like, hey, I use it a lot.
I'm like, if that's your--
more price like you know like that's what you'll
yourself for. So I accepted that.
where I was like, I will be unhappy because I'm the one who
decided to do these things.
And then I--
I like took that step back and I was like,
you know what, fuck it.
After.
being that person for all these years, like I'm not going to kill myself.
like, well, I'm going to choose May.
And then we'll have to figure it out.
Right.
So, I...
I do that all the time where I'm like,
oh, if I become a life coach.
which like the average medium income is like 60.
$5,000 like that's not worth it.
you know or like one time in like a
one time I was like yo this corporate
I should go back to school and be a guidance counselor and like
I could be like a mental health coach as well.
And I was like, oh, I have to do all these things,
spend all this money.
I'm only gonna make this much now.
And then like...
the other day when I was like, "Preshry Walley."
It was like,
bro I'm gonna be a fucking lawyer.
want to but because I would just like really be good.
Add it and then like this is a lot of time.
work and for what is the eye on
we become my like investment into becoming a lot.
I remember all this money out.
So like I--
always do that in my head and like is it
Is the ROI worth it in the end?
Yeah.
Which is good, you should be, rather than just kind of blindly.
throwing yourself into something.
I mean, you've got--
Your husband you got the kids like there's there's depends
dependencies on you that are
kicking in to make you make smart.
choices. So yeah, say, get why.
you haven't necessarily taken the plunge on any of those.
I've thought very similar things myself.
But like to your point, like, yes, like I could--
be doing something now.
I just haven't like what.
because I did that thing where I'm like,
Okay, now that I'm the Canva graphic designer.
professional like I'm like oh I'll start like the at the
and people can like download like
like the fucking like, Santa are letters that... (laughs)
like I can do all that like no traction.
And you know what I mean?
Because I'm like, hey, I downloaded it.
for like a couple bucks.
Right and it didn't work.
And the fact is is I think partly part of it
is you had a...
a VP level job up until
the most recent job that you had.
So the idea--
of doing something like that where the
the, you talk about return and investment like.
your investment of time was a hell of a lot more.
more expensive than what you would be able to.
sell an Etsy product for like just an hourly.
on an hourly basis, I imagine.
that you would be one of the most grossly
overpaid Etsy people on the internet.
internet if you actually were compensated by the amount of
time that you are working. You follow what I'm saying?
Yeah, but it's like those are like easy things
that I do a lot of anyway.
like I'm going to Etsy.
create like my home decor like I'm gonna add
I'm not at the start. Canva create like my kids.
limitations. Thank you, cards, my holiday cards. Like you, I mean, I'm doing...
all of that and making all of this stuff for my
sisters like whatever she needs at school.
So I'm like, oh, like these are easy carry.
over if it makes a couple bucks.
and then if it ever got to the point where it's like an auto download.
where it's like we're just regenerating.
these things because I've bought things off Etsy were
I'm like, oh, I want dinosaur themed rooms for my--
daughter so I don't want them orange green.
and blue, I want them pink purple.
and so like I've gotten that stuff off Etsy and it's just like
of $5 downloaded in the store.
emails that you automatically.
Yeah, so it could be like a
some revenue like income.
for a minute.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I hear what you're saying and I'm sure there's
times we're Nicky wishes that I would just start driving into
Thank you, bird. So that I can have money coming in as well.
- Okay, yeah. - Bye.
What I wanted to ask you now.
Next is you've alluded to like Wally,
getting cold feet about going into business with you.
or having a hard time conceiving.
of working with some of the other people that you've known.
who have been interested in working with you.
What is it that you would... What is it?
that you would need from Wal-Leed if you went into business with him.
I think because it's like it's
different like for us specifically he wanted.
to buy a small, janitorial contract.
like you know star out there.
and like in his mind he's like he's the ops person.
which he is, right? Like he's an ops, janitorial ex.
and he's like, you're the like face, the...
just like strategy, business, side of.
it. Okay. You know, so like that.
makes a lot of sense where like it's just like...
That's a clean one. We're like, I'm not.
Like again, I'm not like, I don't know all the forecare.
like I've never pretended like to be that.
type of expert. So with him, that's like an easy one.
where like I'm the like create
business thinker and the speaker and my
strategy. I'm like this
This is a great idea and he's like, yeah, and he's like the executor.
of like here's how this works. I know how to clean the floors.
like I'll be like hey I need to clean this in my house.
I was like, oh, that's how you do it.
You know what he's like all day.
live up. Right. So that was
was like an easy split for him.
So then the reason that you're not planning
on doing this is because his dad discouraged you guys.
And I'm just asking for clarification.
Like so instead of I was like what about consulting?
like because he said that his dad will get called like from
AB.
and the link do undo a consultant and see like
We need to find vendors for equity.
and then his dad will like jump in and do that.
like what I was like how come your dad like your dad's in
ever. But.
brought you into it. Like, you know what I mean? Like, was like, hey...
and he's like, no, like, we haven't.
And he's like, for a minute, we thought about like,
trying to...
and do something but now.
And I was like, what about like--
the strategy side of it.
Like I said, where it's like--
You know, when Burke went to RFP.
like they hired consultants to like
right playbooks, like someone wrote their playbooks, right?
Like,
someone did a consultancy of like
what they were looking for, you know, like they...
sat with all the current vendors and like asked questions.
about what improvements, like what
ever certain things. Okay.
And I'm like, so think of
it like what we had to do at CSI or
because CSI got like these com...
like they're not life science ready. They're not farmer ready.
and they got business in states that they've
never done business then. So it was like your start.
up like literally like building business like how do you establish
your self or business in Seattle.
And in these
in California, like I
had to build like this, like what is a safety program.
like ground up like risk assessment safety.
program training, right? So I'm like
Well, like it's the same thing. Like I was building playbooks for me.
like at SMR, where I'm like, here's...
how to manage Merck as a client.
Here's our expectations. Here's the processes they follow here.
here's what we follow, here's like, you know what I mean?
So I'm like, why don't you--
do that for or we whoever do that for other companies.
like you want me to build you and I
exceptional like janitorial program.
like here's the KBI, here's how you measure it.
here, but I recommend as this.
Here's the playbook, here's the handbook,
whatever you wanna call it.
Yeah, and then for him, he's...
He was just like, "My dad's on the market, she's saturated."
And he's like,
Because he's like Muslim too, like it's a
cultural thing, you know, like, and I've had to go.
guide him a lot through like this whole.
career thing and where he's like, I'm going to quit.
and he's like, no, my dad says it, whatever.
And I'm like, bro, this--
This is why, like, cause to be honest, I...
haven't told any of my family members. I quit my
for the last like four months.
so that I've been sitting at home, like they all just think I'm...
still working because it's not their business.
And because like culturally like
the generation of our parents like...
they're gonna come in with their beliefs and their feelings.
and they're gonna push them onto me and like I don't need that.
You know, like they come from the culture of like you
you just be grateful you have a job,
everybody hates their job, it can't be.
be that bad. Just suck it up. Find an
new job before you quit all of that and like...
You know my dad I know that he would like my dad's
a pretty aggressive person in relationship anyway, but
like I know he's gonna do it out of hair.
But like he would be like well who's gonna pay your bills? You're gonna
and leave your house, like all these things I'm just like.
you know and I'm like I don't need any of that like it's a
It's hard, it's scary, it's life changing.
whatever, so it's nobody's business.
And that plays into it too, where it's like,
I got them just like lying to this world and like creating this whole...
and how do I get out of it and when will I get out of it but like I'm
And I told them the same thing, I'm like you need to...
to make a decision for you. Like, are you?
you're going to quit? If you're going to quit, then own it.
commit to it and don't let anybody else in
to you while they're right, right? Like, yeah, you don't
don't even have to tell your dad or you just go and tell him you're going to do.
this. Like I know culturally that's not comfortable but like...
That's it or you're not going to quit and you just
have to manage how you're reacting to the situation.
as long as you have to be there.
the same thing with like consultancy or whatever.
because it's your...
right like his dad said no and it was what like just
one and done, but this was only a couple of weeks.
weeks ago. Like this was recent and now.
in the like he's gonna quit phase and he's gonna become a janitor.
So, over here.
revisit. I.
I understand what you mean about like, while
would be the operations arm and you would be the business
management side of things. But everything that you talk me
through as far as like that playbook scenario that you talk about.
talked about and the way that you had
to snap into action to get CSI.
prepared to take over that contract in California.
But like, do you need Wally to do that?
do that? Like why can't you do the thing that you just...
said you had to do why can't that just
be your your offer. No, I
like Wally, I did it with Wally.
like he joined at the beginning and we
did do it together. Like there were things that I would not have
known for sure. Not to say that
but like I can't figure things out.
but like to say I was an expert and would have been able like
like he did a lot.
He did like a lot of
like the operational development.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
That I will like it.
him. I feel like they...
The thing that I'm trying to push you on Jenna is that I don't know-
that like as great of a guy
while it sounds like he does and you guys are friends.
Like I don't think that you need him.
to be successful in
Whatever you continue to do next. Like I think...
there is a niche that you can operate in.
and where whoever you would be.
consulting with has that operations on
that Wal-Eid is theoretically providing for you.
you if you went into business with him. But if he's going to
to have a really hard time thinking about
making a jump like this or he's going to defer to his
dad on it? Like that shouldn't hold you.
back and I feel like you are fully capable.
of doing something by yourself without him.
on board.
Yeah.
- No, I agree.
I think.
like there's comfort in your life.
buddy thinking, right? Like we're having a partner.
but also like my.
My jump is not, I think like...
I'm not a hundred percent like oh this
This is the only thing I can do.
That I--
have to do it. Like you know what I mean? I think that's like more.
like what a whole got to hold up but it was it's like
like, yeah, that is great.
Like, I--
I could do that.
Is the market like--
saturated there are probably yes there are probably other people who do this.
like I know people like Lee of CBRI and whatever and they've found
and to do similar things. So it's like is that
that if it's just me, like, right?
like I'm not borrowing skillsetter.
crossover is that the right the exact right there.
for me.
Like, does it have to be operations? Does it have to be janitorial?
like and that's almost where it's like I was
I was talking to Molly about this this morning because like
again like the whole if-ment type thing or the f-f.
PMP, ethnic certifications, et cetera.
like, "Am I gonna do it because it's the next?"
like, and logically, like, I'm
coming this far, I go this way.
I was like, or if I
Like it did, let's say like...
like the life coaching or something, like is there a
a correlation.
Like, is there a value to business?
In doing that, like how could I like
What do I get from that?
You know what I mean?
To be like.
to bring it in for like executive like really.
really should management or like team.
like that's the correlation I was trying like
most recently today thinking about.
You know like what other things because like
Does it have to be something industry specific?
But like I've gotten like my six Sigma Greenbelt.
that like I've never like, Matt charted out.
like a problem. Like you know that's
never friend like a push for anything.
Like if I have like
life coaching thing like is there
benefit. Should I go and do like...
I don't know.
Like you get to...
I'm not on a column silly, but you can
do like very
different executive paths about like
like management about like team building, you know, like.
It does any of that bring any of that.
like what is going to bring like a differential to you?
May.
in any type of career since right now.
Now I'm like, broad, you know what I mean?
I feel like the way that you can hone it.
down is just thinking about what is
it that people have responded best.
from you. What have you heard repeatedly over the
about people's experience of working with you.
you. And so when
whether it's literally life coaching or just
What kind of...
Like sensibility, what kind of...
of expertise but not necessarily subject matter.
expertise. What is a way, what is
a kind of problem that you are particularly good at.
solving for people or for or for
organizations and then that is the thing.
that you build your...
your independent enterprise around.
As opposed to like the thing that I've just
give you a more concrete example. The thing that I've...
had to kind of deprogram.
myself from is.
You work on proposals for a living for 12 years.
And you convince yourself that you are the best.
there to be producing artifacts for people.
reality is that that is what I was doing.
when I first got the job, but I didn't get
subsequent jobs just because I was good at making art.
facts. I got subsequent jobs because I was able
to convince people that I had ideas when I would
interviewing with them and when I would talk to them during...
during bids. And so...
So for me, that is like the angle that I'm...
looking to take is cutting out the
strict adherence to I'm the guy who produces
the thing and maybe you'll hear interesting ideas.
for me along the way if you give a shit which.
Not everybody does. But ultimately...
Like that's what I'm weaponizing as opposed to something
something that's more concrete.
And it's scary.
think that way, but I think that that is.
what the answer is as far as like
question about differentiators. And so for you.
what would that thing be? And I think that's what you should...
should be trying to be thinking about.
Because that will--
also help to steer you in the
the right direction for a W-2 job if that is...
the way that you want to go.
And I think that was like the miss at SVM when like...
I first went into like...
a contract renewal like or or the whole process.
with work, right, is because like for me I'm like...
as an organization any or anytime.
right like anytime like when we had to do what I had to do like
like an executive presentation that like
should have been done by like Val and
Charles, like to...
or C-suite and whatever, doesn't the company have
a message like doesn't the company have something that they're
want to sell like you know or or
Or like that term like is there a basis?
'Cause that...
to some degree there is carryover, right?
understand like customizing to the client the need the
market, the industry, whatever, the round.
the vertical but like I was always kind of
like, well, what is like, espionage?
like what are we gonna tell these people and like their own?
always like, no, that's not how this works.
Like, and that's what I'm--
where I would get like in, I guess like, at trouble.
everyone right because it's like I
I don't know if it was you or someone else where I was like, "Hey, is there..."
anything you can share with me from like the other RVs.
they could start looking at and they're like, "Oh no, that's your don't your..."
you're getting interval like that's not how we do this kind of thing.
like, you know, had to like ground up.
bottom up, like figure that out.
And like that's like--
like that's where I'm like, don't we have like.
a team like a proposal team where
they're creating solutions.
the general market problem in
right? Like that's kind of what I thought. Like...
right now, like, what is the, how is the
the company itself positioning themselves
and what is our solution.
in general for what we're selling and then like
take it from there, customize it, and whatever.
And like, so that's where I'm like, that's where you.
come in, right? Like you do the
for the company like everything doesn't have
to be a ground up build like we should be able to.
framework things.
- Right.
- And that's all.
why I used to like when I would listen.
to like someone else present something?
like in the few and rare moments that we got to,
'cause we were all.
always so like siloed, but I'm like, if I listen to
I'll give a presentation if I listen to Sean Henderson.
and give a great station like I'm gonna learn and steal something.
from them, right?
Like, oh, I could say like I heard this, or--
we're doing that. But that's not
how SMA worked and that's not how like teeth.
work, right? Like, I guess until I made the first
work that everyone was using.
Exactly.
So like your theory-
I think I'm like almost
aligned with like what you're saying if not you
you know, you can correct me where it's like you.
didn't need to like, 'cause even I love Jessica.
I know I'm like all of this.
I loved working with Jasson.
and everything, but like she didn't,
she also didn't give me.
me like much strategy for my coast.
She like took all of my stuff and helped me.
format it and helped me, you know, like.
put it nicely into one th-
- Right.
- So like.
I thought, you know, like, you're saying, we're--
like, well, I can give you like the ideas to answer.
market solutions or to you know to exclude.
solutions to market problems and like how to differentiate eight years.
yourself as a company.
And, you know,
That's really more sorry.
So like I got, I got.
what you're listening from.
which just never made sense to me.
But again,
I mean, Chris Luther made
that happen right? Like once I'm
made one good presentation. He just started giving the same presentation.
over and over and over and over again.
Yeah, yeah, I mean what what
What that shows is...
I think a good way to kind of summarize that is just like,
where you are able to
not just be thinking about
The thing that's directly in the video is that you can see the video.
in front of you that you are producing for this like short term.
term thing, you're thinking about how can we make something that's really
usable and repeatable.
But like credibly so and not
just for out of a sense of laziness.
out of a sense of it is beneficial to have
a consistent story and how an organ is
and the organization presents itself.
- Yeah.
And the reason why that may not be.
happen at a given place is because...
the people who are...
In theory, med2, execute on...
putting together that story, whether it's in a proposal or marketing.
They're not being given a straight story, but
but they're also not being empowered by the process.
to come up with the story.
So it just basically means that you have...
are having to kind of make it up as you go along.
But I do think--
think that there is a lot of value that organization.
could get out of working with somebody.
who is is.
oriented in that way. Like that.
That's like, yeah, that's solutions architecture.
is systems thinking.
And I know I'm just--
just kind of throwing out random as buzzwords, but like.
That is a genuinely useful and not particular
common trait to have in
And so just trying to think of like how to position.
yourself and you know what might work for you in the future.
future. Like, I think that's really more.
You're lame rather than rather than
being the person who has to come in and like heroically.
the startup for BMS or.
you know whatever that situation was that you had to deal with.
It just feels like you're capable of doing
it but you are not.
are not like it's not maximizing
Yeah, like I'm tired
I'm like, I want to lead, I want to like teach not to.
Like at this point, like I don't want to do this.
I just want to show you all how to do it.
essentially. Right. Right. Um.
is kind of where I'm like at now.
my head and I do that's why I
It lends itself well to consulting.
It also is like super unique because like as I
like listen to Walid and try to give him advice like
and then he'll just be like, is it us?
Like our--
Is it us? Like really genuinely. I'm like, no, it is us.
like because we want solutions, we want.
like long-term problem solving, we want to put across this in place.
We want to correct it. We want to understand why it was broken.
and make sure it never is broken again and nobody else.
that we've ever met wants to do that. They want to just like.
Get it done, move on and not worry about it.
I'm like, so.
So it is us because to everybody else.
we probably look like we're overcomplicating it.
Like we're you know like making it too serious we're overcome
like I don't care how you do this, just get it done.
and then like we're like
We should have a process and let's do analysis and why.
I don't care who broke it, but why did it break to begin?
with so that we can fix why it broke and it'll never.
break again. We don't have to just yell at that one person.
and like which hunt and whatever and that's not the one.
world that we live in or the industry that we're working in.
I'm like, so it probably is us.
like we are the problem to them.
because we're different.
Yeah, exactly.
And I think...
I think I've had my wrist slapped for similar reasons throughout.
the years as well where, you know, if
If you are being looked at as the person who is
in my specific situation, like making the art effect.
You it's like I need you to be put
out fires like that is the
I need you to be doing things ad hoc
as opposed to proactively.
And I think if you naturally grab
to imitate towards that macro style.
of thinking, which I'll say as a
somebody who also has ADHD is
something that like is it's like I can't
can't not do it.
Like that's just how my brain works and I am--
Imagine that it's the same thing for you.
Yeah, I'm like, I don't...
Like, I will sit in so many of the conversations.
and I'm like, this is
the wrong we're having the wrong conversation like we're not.
And we're not talking about like the actual.
point of like what needs to be spoken about.
unlike are we ignoring these things?
Let's like, and I'm like, I'm like.
Listen, this is what they want. Just do it and like
I do this to everyone, but I'll listen to it.
like no this is why he's angry this is what you know any
like this is what you did that made him frustrated.
Whether I...
I agree with it or not.
I'm like, Nick doesn't like your response because--
of this. You may can feel like this type of...
by saying that. Like Nick doesn't want you.
you to do like this.
He just wants you to do
it. Just go do it. You know like...
like I don't know I'm just trying to help you figure out how to
make Nick happy. (laughs)
Yeah, and like you have that ability to...
Zoom out and kind of see the context in which it's happening.
instead of being wrapped around the axle.
on the fact that it's happening.
I guess it's a...
Yeah, like I'm like I'm always like on in on the
the devil's advocate person.
I'm like, here's both, I'm like,
you want me to argue both sides, I can tell you what both sides.
the side is this and that side is that and then you decide.
and what you want to do.
Like, generally, that is literally what consulting is.
you get brought in to provide that kind of
of thought, but you don't own the
accountability as far as the decision that's actually being made.
You are there to help people to make decisions.
Like that?
Like if...
That's something that you naturally do.
You talk about like, oh, like you're you're already making
things that you can make money on Etsy like this applies to like
If your brain is already doing this, people
People are going to respond worse.
when you are in a W-2 full time.
position where they just want you to be doing a job.
But if your brain is...
Yeah.
where you're, but if your brain is up in space and you're,
not in not in a pejorative way, but if your brain is like
doing galaxy brain things and you're thinking about
the whole context of it and everybody else around you.
you as their head buried.
That's the mismatch, but if you are invited...
specifically to do that kind of thinking.
because you were demonstrably good at it.
will make you feel good about the work that you're doing.
you're doing in a way that I know I haven't felt.
good about being told like shut up and just.
you know, get back to doing the thing that I asked you to do.
Yeah.
No, it's true because like I've
Like my theory like you you
change yourself early, you kind of thing.
'Cause like, no company ever.
actually wants to change regardless of what they...
say, you know, and it's like,
So either you're going to just do it this way.
airway or you're going to have to leave.
I believe has always been like my major.
problem because... Right.
And to be fair, like I just...
I did have a lot of leeway and ownership.
like you know there was a lot of like bullshit.
spam stuff. We all have to do certain.
and Charles stuff, but there was a live.
I definitely was like the first of many.
or, you know, like to do certain things or...
to ask about certain things and I just kind of like did.
stuff that I was like.
It's even the same at Lake Seaside because no one told me anything.
And I'm like, well, I'm gonna get it done.
And if you don't want to tell me your way, I'll just do them.
mine, like we're gonna have equipment on
the first day so like either I'm gonna order it all in a credit card.
or you're going to tell me like how to procure equipment.
Like, you know, if you don't get done, trust me.
be the way you want it done because you never fucking told me.
You know, Tony just...
like left for three week vacation.
Like, you know.
and didn't tell me shit. I'm like, "What's this? I'll just..."
I'll just figure it out.
Yeah, I- I-
I do genuinely think that you would be well-sewed.
to it Jenna and I mean I
Would love to help you with getting
getting you reoriented in that direction.
or whether that's like looking for W2 jobs.
that are explicitly asking for you to be.
thinking that way or trying to set up something.
yourself. I think that you are driven and...
disciplined enough to do it on your own?
And I gotta say that even though I don't actually have any-
income on the horizon right now and for that matter.
My whole goddamn family doesn't because Nikki doesn't have a job yet
I am still so much.
I feel like a giant thing has been taken off.
off my back because I have the aid
agency to make it so that I have income coming.
in and not hoping that.
My company will tolerate it.
me long enough for me to just
to get the money is the way that I would put it.
Yeah, like I can.
I understand, like, you know what I mean?
Because you're putting...
time and effort into yourself.
Right, like it's going to be a direct product.
of what you're working on the time.
you put into it and the success that you make out of it versus.
like just another white guy too.
It's an amazing credit. That's something I think.
I mean no thanks.
to take it out of it. Well, but think of it.
I mean, every, like, and I guess.
I guess Marvin was white, but like some guy took a credit for everything.
I've ever done like you're in like
I didn't do anything at BMS, I saved BMS.
Someone's...
and all probably got the credit.
Lake Fucking Chris and Jeff didn't sell.
BMS, ISO BMS, someone else got the credit.
Like, you know, Marvin got his whole promotion.
off of everything that I did.
I understand what you're saying, where it's like your...
this is going to be you, like, if you fail at you.
if you succeeded to you. It's not an outline.
there. You're not going to take the blame for fogging
What's her name? What's that girl's name?
you're all boss Veronica.
Victoria. I don't know why I can never run.
remember her name. I'm like Vivian, Virac.
- I could never remember. - I could never remember.
name. This Terminator Barbie how about
that. She was.
like bizarre. I think.
She really was.
Yeah, I think she...
This is not a knock against people who are neurodivergent.
but I think she has some undiagnosed asperger or something.
like that like and if she was a
of it then like she could work with it but she's
not working with it. I don't know why it's not self-aware. That's the worst.
kind of neurodivergent person.
I told I like set this to like my
the doctor I see from my ADHD meds.
It was like...
I wish that I was ignorant and not self-aware.
I think my life would be so much happier.
And she's like, what do you know?
I was like, I would just do whatever the fuck I want.
say whatever I want, not care about what I want.
what I'm doing, why I'm doing it, who I'm.
hurting.
Haha, any of that.
I'm just really grateful.
Like I was like, I just want to be dumb.
And...
Not self-wear.
I feel like yeah, I feel like
Yeah, I can relate to that idea.
I can.
Yeah, but this is why I went to like...
life coaching or whatever because like there's a
book that I like started to read but I
cannot do self-help books, but it's called like man that doesn't love
and it's like the theory of it is like your kids.
have like different needs and you kind of like manage
people as people, like how ironic, right?
where you like, you know, like.
treat like what my manager embossed.
and it's my manager in San Francisco might.
not need and like they might not be receptive.
And like so I would I would do that like I just
like listen to people like kind of like how you're doing that like I just
listen.
will talk. I give way too much time.
like to them, like you.
I hope that I might listen to them.
I'm like...
Okay, what I like I'll do for all but like I know
that you might need this, you might need that.
right and then they would always say like what they were
missing when I was gone. They're like we need the translator.
like the Merc translator, like it's not that
that they can't execute it, but they're like,
I don't, like you would take a merk ass.
and you would come in and be like,
this is what Mark's asking.
Like this is what it means in layman terms or whatever.
And then we all be like, oh, that makes sense.
Okay, let's do this.
or you'd be like, you know, give us a guidance and then we'd go and do it.
But then like Marvin whoever back failed me would come in and date in on
like they're like, I don't know, just figure it out.
Like why can't you?
you just do it.
But you know, and then they're like
to Jenna do all of your jobs and it's like no but
like she kind of like started.
the brainstorming? Yeah. Is that
make sense and then you know like or something.
Sometimes I'd be talking and someone'd be like,
no, no, you're talking in Merck.
You need to like try.
and they're all really sad when I...
because they're like, no one's gonna listen to me,
and I'm like, they're not.
like they're really not.
of things like times, conversations that I've had with people.
and like the amount of time I spent like just
listening to them. No one's gonna do that.
They're hot. And. Right.
that's, but then that's the difference, right?
because I would get on a call.
And now so, like, while it'll be like...
Oh no, this is your breathing.
pattern is changed which means this or they'd be like
We can tell in your voice that, like, what did we need to do?
Like, how--
How can we help you?
They just like, you know.
would jump in and like know that I would support them.
So they would support me, whereas Marvin and every person.
person who replaced me with 10 emails and be like, somebody needs to be there.
So whatever, and everyone be like,
I'm not fucking answering you.
like I'm not doing that. Yeah there's no one.
- Yeah, and Tony said that to me too.
like when Walid was coming over, he's like...
This guy must really trust you.
That was like all...
Fuck don't tell me that
- Hey, he's telling me that, Tony.
He's like, he's leaving his house.
like establish job for you like he that's.
That's a testament to you and what you built.
with him and your team and they'll say now you're
essentially telling me I have two families to support because anything
that goes wrong is my fault.
I think that's not quite the case, but...
I can understand why you would go there.
especially given what you were saying about the the self-aware
thing like it's I I you.
I have a similar trait where it's like I can't just think of
about the thing in and of itself, I have to,
you have to,
like meta thoughts about the thing and
And it's, I'm sure it's really helpful.
in a lot of context, in other ways you're like, like you said.
I wish I was dumb and not self-aware so
that I wouldn't be having meta thoughts all the time.
Yeah, I wanna like...
not care.
Like, I want to like...
And it's I keep telling everybody
that I'm in my my villain era.
They're like, I think it's like your justice era
'cause I'm like...
like my, I did like this whole like,
like winter solstice like.
like give your mom whatever to the world type.
things so and learn them and like whatever the world.
takes all the ones that get burned and then like whatever your life
with is like you were saying that you're supposed to hear through the year.
So like my thing for 2026 and I'm
with thick areas like no is a false sentence.
Like this.
This is my whatever.
So I just am all about shutting people down.
where I'm like yeah
No, this is non-value like my poor
husband. Like when we were not having the same conversation.
and there's no value in this now, so when you're ready, just let me know.
I feel kind of like my vibes for like this year.
Yeah, I'll take your leave.
I'm just like, no, it's not.
And people will be like, that's me.
and whatever I say. I'm like, yeah well.
It's the truth this year.
Bye.
It's also strategic.
smart move a lot of the time. I wish it again.
Nikki and I have gotten to that point too,
where like I will.
not take her lead about like
Hey, let's maybe table this. Let's like...
stop having this unproductive conversation.
for a minute and they'll be like no I'm angry and I want to talk
more. So it's good because then...
you can mitigate the potential of getting yourself.
to that point where you're like not being productive anymore.
it's a good thing for sure.
Yeah, that's something like trying to.
do or I'm like I'm not going to protect other people's feelings.
for my feelings anymore, like this year.
- Go ahead.
where I'm like, okay.
Yes, I'm the psycho because they yelled, but let's also.
play out the 20,000 things that happened before we got here.
So everybody who heard me all knows that like your side
go to. Like this is this is there.
I'm in, I'm like, you wanna like be a jerk.
I'll report you to your company like...
Whatever, I'm going for it. Totally going for it.
this year. Good. Good. I...
I am happy for you with that journey.
journey. I imagine you do too, but I gotta.
get ready to go pick up Billy from school.
I appreciate you talking me off the lunch.
I've got
I'll keep thinking.
I gotta figure something out.
Yeah.
I have some ideas that I want to percolate a little bit about.
for you as well and I can follow up with those.
because I genuinely think that...
you should be...
doing your own thing and if you did then I would really want to help.
you with that and whatever form that takes.
So let's keep that going.
Let's keep that moving.
momentum going.
Okay, sounds good.
Yeah, I'm gonna
I'm gonna think more and I think like try the new.
resonates as well and then but we'll keep we'll keep in
schedule follow up.
>> Sure.
Okay, well sounds good.
Thank you again, I appreciate it.
- Yeah, sure.
I'll talk to you soon.
OK.
Bye.